Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firat, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant der Taty
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahme-Geschreif führen.
Wenn Sie fragen haben, dann etwas nicht festehen,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemein Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Michel Müller.
Michel Müller.
Können Sie Ihr Vorname und Nachname langsam und deutlich büchtern?
Natürlich. Mein Vorname ist M. W. Martha, I. W. Ida, C. W. Caesar, H. W. Heinrich, A. W. Anton, E. W. Emil, L. W. Ludwig.
Mein Nachname ist M. W. Müller, Ü. W. Übel, L. W. Ludwig, L. W. Ludwig, E. W. Emil, L. W. Richard.
Okay. M. Michael Müller, ich spreche Ihren Namen richtig aus.
M. Müller, reicht aus. M. Müller.
M. Müller. Okay. Wie alt sind Sie, M. Müller?
45 Jahre alt.
45 Jahre alt. Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 22. Juni 1979 geboren.
Okay. 22. Juni 1979 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie, M. Müller?
Ich bin 1,80 m groß und wiege circa 90 kg.
Okay. Sie sind 180 cm groß und sie wiegt 90 kg.
Genau.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns, M. Müller?
Ich komme zu Ihnen, weil ich sehr starke Bauchschmerzen habe.
Bauchschmerzen haben Sie. Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Sie sind eher im Oberbau.
Oberbau.
Indermitte, linken Seite oder rechte Seite?
Indermitte.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit der Nacht schon, also seit ungefähr 8-9 Stunden.
8-9 Stunden.
Seit der Nacht.
Okay. Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich aufgetreten.
Plötzlich.
Ja, gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel nach dem Essen oder Stress.
Ist es in der Nacht aufgetreten?
In der Nacht plötzlich.
Ja.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Schreiben die Schmerzen auch am Rücken.
Indermitte.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Die ganze Zeit.
Dauerhaft.
Haben Sie dabei Brustschmerzen, Luftnode oder Herzrasen?
Nein.
Okay.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen sichern oder schmerzen?
Das sind ja so stetschende Druckende Schmerzen.
Stetschende und druckende Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10 vorbei?
Ein leichter Schmerz, sind sehr stark schmerzend?
8 und 9.
Ja, Sie haben sehr stark Schmerzen und ich mache schnell damit,
ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Ist es das erste Mal oder hatten Sie schon früher eine Schmerz?
Ich habe das noch nie gehabt.
Zu stark Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Noch nicht.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihr Haut gerbt geworden ist?
Nein.
Haben Sie Yukrais?
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrochen?
Ja, ich habe richtig Übelkeit, ich habe auch schon 2 Mal mich erbrochen.
2 Mal erbrochen?
Seit gestern Abend?
Seit der Nacht.
Wie sagt das Erbrochen aus?
Gar nicht.
Gar nicht?
Gibt es Blut im Erbrechen?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe noch kein Stuhlgang gehabt.
Seit wann?
Seit der Nacht.
Früher haben Sie Probleme?
Nein.
Ein Stuhlgang?
Ich habe nicht geholfen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Vollgefühl oder Belegungen haben?
Ja, ich bin etwas aufgebläht, ich habe eher so ein Vollgefühl.
Vollgefühl.
Haben Sie Zotbrenen, Zauber aufstessen bemerkt?
Aktuell nicht, nein.
Früher haben Sie?
Selten, manchmal, wenn ich zu viel gegessen habe oder zu viel getrunken habe.
Viel gegessen oder viel getrunken habe.
Haben Sie etwas gegönnchen, dass Sie angehen?
Ich habe eine Ibuprofen annehmen müssen, weil ich nicht ausgehalten habe.
Wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
400 Milligramm.
Wie oft haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe es nur einmal eingenommen.
Hat das geholfen?
Ich habe immer noch Schmerzen, deswegen bin ich jetzt hier.
Ich habe nicht geholfen.
Was essen Sie normalerweise, Herr Müller?
Essen Sie gerne Fleischwurst, Käse?
Alles, ich esse alles.
Okay, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen, so ihr allgemein so stehen zu stellen.
Haben Sie verstärkt im Durst bemerkt?
Hab ich was?
Verstärkt im Durst.
Sie möchten sehr viel Wasser trinken.
Sie haben ihr Appetit?
Wahrscheinlich vermutet Sie haben nicht gut Appetit wegen Übelkeit.
Ich habe jetzt seit der Nacht nichts gegessen, aber gestern habe ich gut gegessen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht abgenommen oder so genommen?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Hüste?
Nein.
Fühlen Sie sich schwindelig?
Haben Sie schon einmal bewusst sein verloren?
Noch nie.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Stülfrost?
Nein.
Keine Fieber, kein Stülfrost.
Oder haben Sie nachschweiß, kaltschweiß oder schweiß Ausbrüche?
Ja, ich schwitze schon, weil ich sehr stark Schmerzen habe.
Ich schwitze sehr.
Okay.
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal im Urlaub?
Im Sommer.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Sie wissen nicht?
Nein. Was heißt denn vollständig geimpft?
Ja, alle Kindheit der Impfung hatten Sie.
Denke schon, ja.
Ich werde Ihnen eine unangenehme Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Geschehlechtfeket?
Nein.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Gibt es chronische Erkrankungen bei Ihnen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Vielleicht Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich bin eigentlich gesund.
Sie sind gesund.
Okay. Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich habe eine Augenoperation gehabt, als ich klein war, aber ansonsten nicht.
Warum wurde Ihnen eine Augenoperation durchgeführt?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr ganz.
Sie wissen nicht.
Okay. Ja, jetzt kommen wir zu den Medikamenten.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente, ein regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Auser überprüfen.
Nein.
Okay. Haben Sie allegigegegeln etwas?
Hausstopp.
Hausstopp. Okay. Hausstopp.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Mit Niesen, Kaumenjucken.
Kaumenjucken.
Und Niesen.
Okay. Und Niesen. Ja.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Gewohnheit stellen.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rachen?
Ich rauche ja.
Wie viel Skate rachen Sie und seid du?
Ungefähr 10-10 Retteland-Tage.
Ich rauche schon seit ca. 15 Jahren ungefähr.
15 Jahren. Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Was trinken Sie und wie viel trinken Sie?
Ich trinke meistens Bier.
Bier?
Ja. Und wie viel trinken Sie?
Also jeden Tag zu 2-3 Flaschen.
2-3 Flaschen, ja.
Das ist ein bisschen viel. Okay.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich bin geschiedet seit ungefähr 6 Monaten.
Und seitdem trinke ich etwas mehr.
Okay.
Und haben Sie weniger getrunken?
Ja.
Seit 6 Monaten? Ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie mir nächste Frage nicht über.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie keine Drogen genommen?
Ja.
Okay. Das freut mich.
Sie sind gleich fertig, aber ich brauche noch ein paar Informationen.
Sie haben ihre Familiengeschichte.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Beide leben noch, ja.
Ja, super.
Und welche Krankheit gibt es bei Ihren Eltern,
zum Beispiel Volotochturuk oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Also mein Vater hat Lungenkrebs.
Und meine Mutter hat soweit ich weiß,
nur eine Schilddrösenunterfunktion.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist 73 Jahre alt.
Meine Mutter ist um, ich glaube 68, müsste es jetzt sein.
68 Jahre alt.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Okay.
Wir haben es gleich geschafft.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen, so Ihrer Sozialstatus.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin KFZ-Mechanika.
Mechanika?
Genau, KFZ. Ich repariere Autos.
Mechanika, okay.
Sind Sie mit der Arbeit zufrieden?
Nein.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Jeden Tag.
Okay. Das tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter.
Ist sie gesund?
Gott sei Dank, ja.
Haben Sie Partnerin oder Partner?
Ich bin geschieden seit 6 Monaten.
Ja, ich weiß, Sie sind geschieden, aber vielleicht haben Sie auch.
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Kein Partner.
Auserst Stress bei der Arbeit,
haben Sie auch Stress im Privatleben oder finanziellen Sorge?
Ja, ihr seid der Scheidung.
Slecht alles.
Ja, das tut mir leid.
Okay.
Herr Müller, wir sind jetzt mit dem Gespräch fertig.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt eine Körperleihuntersuchung machen.
Dann wird das Labo abnehmen und eine Ultraschall des Abdomens durchführen.
Sobald Ihre Befunde vorliegen,
bespreche ich mit meinem Oberarzt, dann komme ich zu Ihnen.
Ich erkläre Ihnen, dass Sie mit der Unterkunft
in der Unterkunft sind.
Nein, ich verstehe.
Ich gebe sofort ein Schmerzmittel.
Danke.
Wir hören nicht.
Haben Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Was haben Sie in der Abend?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Was haben Sie in der Abend gegessen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben mit der Unterkunft
in der Unterkunft
im Sorge,
über die Unterkunft
in der Unterkunft
einen Schmerzmittel.
Das war links-seitig, rechts-seitig, oder gultelformig?
Mitesch.
Gultelformig oder?
Mittik.
Okay.
Ist diese Schmerz'n Kolikartik?
Oder imada?
Imada.
Sie haben gesagt...
Frau, Frau, Frau, Frau, Frau, Frau, Frau.
Ja.
Zwei Frage.
Okay, das ist das letzte. Danke schön.
Ich würde gerne wissen, haben Sie die letzte drei Tagen Schutulfarbe-Veränderung?
Nein, da ist noch mal.
Okay.
Wir müssen in dem Fall unterbrechen, oder?
In so einem Fall.
Wenig Schmerzen?
Ja.
Ja, das wäre ganz gut.
Das wäre gut, ja.
Aber erst mal müssen Sie fragen.
Aber erst mal muss man untersuchen, natürlich.
Ja.
Also nicht sofort Schmerz-Virgament geben, sondern Sie müssen abtasten im Bauch.
Ja, natürlich.
Und...
Ja, vielleicht, wenn Sie eine Infusion geben, können Sie schon untersuchen.
Ja.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ja, diese Schmerz'n Sehsteig, ich mache es schon.
Damit ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben kann.
Ist das reicht, oder?
Nein.
Sie haben sich ja versucht zu bemühen, aber der Patient hat ja Schmerzen.
Da sollte man vielleicht schnell untersuchen kurz, wo die Schmerzen sind.
Und deine Schmerzen, die kann man dann hängen, damit der Patient nicht sehr leidet
und dann weitermachen mit der Anomese.
Ja.
Parallel vielleicht arbeitet, oder?
Okay, verstehe.
Noch an der Frage.
Kollegen, können wir anfangen, Schmerz?
Ja, natürlich.
Schön.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Mein Name ist Schmerz Firat.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Es geht um Herr Michael Müller.
Er ist fünf Jahre alt.
Er ist fünf und viert
und am zweiten
CANNY
1970 geboren d.
Er ist 180 cm groß
und wirkt 90 kg.
Er stellt sich bei uns
wegen seit der nacht
bestehenden Schmerzen
Schmerzen im Epigastrium vor. Laut Aussage der Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich in der Nacht aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den Rücken ausschütteren und die Schmerzintensität bei 8-9 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala-Sin liegt.
Nach Angabe der Patienten sind die Schmerzen stechend und drückend und progredient.
Er hat dagegen Ibuprofen angenommen, aber Ibuprofen hat nicht geholfen.
Er begleitet, klagt über Neusea, 2 Mal Gems und gar nicht mehr Schüssel ab der Nacht.
Er hat sich in der Nacht geholfen und die Schmerzen in der Nacht geholfen.
Er hat eine Schmerz-Ausbrüche und eine Hyperhydroze.
Er hat eine Verbrauchung von der Schmerz-Ausbrüche.
Er hat die Schmerz-Ausbrüche von 7,5 von 10 bis 4 Flaschen abgenommen.
Er hat seit 6 Monaten weniger Schmerzen getroffen.
Er hat eine Schmerz-Ausbrüche.
Er ist ein Sozialanamnist.
Er hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit und im Privatleben.
Er hat eine Anamnistik am ersten Angriff von einem Akute-Pankratitis.
Er hat eine differenzialen Diagnostik.
Er hat eine Verbrauchung von der Schmerz-Ausbrüche.
Er hat 2 bis 4 Flaschen abgenommen.
Er hat eine Sonografie des Abdomens.
Er hat eine Konzerte des Abteilungs- und Fugaster-Antereleger.
Er hat eine Diagnose der 5-Tage-Ausbrüche.
Der Patient sollte stationär abgenommen werden.
Er sollte Infusion-Therapie, Physik-Zufuhr und Elektrolyte-Sustation
und symptomatische Behandlung wie Analgetika, Antihematika, Erhaltung.
Bei Billiare Genese wird ein ERCP durchgeführt.
Bei Necrotysin-Pancreatitis, aber erwarten wir hier nicht,
aber ein Antibiotika wird eingesetzt.
Natürlich spielt das hier große Rolle.
Patientenschulungen, Alkoholkarrens und Necrotysin-Karrens werden empfohlen.
Das war alles.
Sie gehen hier vor einer alkoholinduzierten Akute in Pancreatitis aus.
Ja, ich habe so gedacht.
Es muss nicht immer gürtelfürmig sein, wie die klassische Pancreatitis.
Manchmal ist es nur ein starker epigastischer Schmerz mit Ausstrahlung,
dass es nicht immer mehr vermerrt sein kann.
Die Therapie ist klar.
Es ist alles wunderschön.
Es ist wichtig, dass es nicht so oft bei alkoholinduzit,
weil es nicht so oft kräft ist.
Man sollte auf Volumen und Zuwahr achten.
Man sagt nicht mehr, wie früher man soll 3 Tage nüchtern bleiben.
Man kann nahe umgeben, aber es ist wichtig, dass man Volumen und Zuwahr achten kann.
Es ist ganz wichtig.
Und natürlich die Alkoholkarrens.
Ich habe vergessen, dass es so nennen kann.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Gibt es Ergänzungen?
Gibt es Einwände dagegen?
Das ist der differenzial Diagnose.
Hier ist die Pancreatitis naheliegend wegen der Anamnese.
Bei alkoholinduzit erwarten wir nicht so viel eine Ausstrahlung.
Das ist nicht Ausstrahlung.
Deswegen habe ich es gerade gesagt, es muss nicht immer gut sein.
Das ist klassisch, aber es gibt natürlich auch Pancreatitis,
die einfach nur epikrastische Schmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken haben.